time for just a few questions today we
invited annie and all that we get and we
picked out the best one shireen at
robert fembers wants to know
the brown's most impressive victory next
season
opponent and score
i left my crystal ball downstairs
shireen do you have any thoughts on
the brown's most impressive win next
year and maybe what the score will be
you know
100 to nothing well you know when i read
that i was thinking it said last year's
most impressive win and i'm thinking
well of course it's the steelers in the
postseason right
i think they sweep the steelers next
year i'll say that i'll go there i think
they're going to have a better team than
the steelers
i'm going to say they're going to sweep
the steelers this season i don't know
what the scores are going to be the
steelers killed them in the first game
and then they got the steelers twice
uh in two weeks in a row by the way uh
including in the postseason so i i'm
gonna go with that that they're gonna
they're gonna sweep the steelers and
that'll be their big uh
big mark for this year and i won't go
100 to nothing but i
vividly recall week one 1989
steelers at the browns actually it was
brown
the steelers to make it even worse the
steelers were the home team for this
debacle
51 to nothing was the win by the browns
over the steelers so maybe they get to
do it in week one again this year
picking up right where they left off
with the win in pittsburgh in the
playoffs go into a full
potentially heinz field and get the 51
to nothing win as
a bookend 32 years after the fact of
what they did
once upon a time at three rivers stadium
at nick west 14 if
aaron rodgers gets the full-time
jeopardy hosting gig which
he clearly wants isn't it plausible he
plays one season and just rides off into
his 30 years
of jeopardy you know we've talked about
this a lot of different ways shireen
could he get jeopardy to wait until
after the season and he takes the job
he thinks he can double dip some think
he could like tape
a whole football season of shows before
football season
begins i don't think the producers would
be into that
but i i if he gets off of the job i
think he's going to find a way to take
the job however much more football he
can play
yeah and i do think mike if there's an
mvp award and a super bowl attached to
the season i think he could ride off
into the sunset like peyton manning did
and john elway did i do think this could
be his last year but can he do that
i don't know we're going to find out but
if jeopardy wants him i think he's going
to jeopardy
last one from the real sulphez is denver
pressed to trade up in the draft
division's only getting better another
bad year can cause fanjoy's job here's
the easy answer to that one
george payton doesn't care if vic fangio
gets fired look this is how it works new
gm wants his own coach he can say
whatever he wants
george payton has been walking around
with 15
years of lists in his in his pants
pocket of the guys that he would want to
hire as head coach
and he's going to do what's right for
the team he's not going to do what's
right for vic fangio
and if they stink this year and vic
fangio gets fired then george payton can
hire whoever it is
is at the top of that list of the guys
that he wants to hire to be his head
coach shereen
yeah i think teddy we talked about could
be a good bridge quarterback no pun
intended
in denver and then they go back to the
drawing board maybe after next season
they see what teddy can become
at 28 years old so that would be a
possibility there i don't think they're
pressed mike to go find that quarterback
because george payton's new on the job
he's not pressed to get it done this
year
and think about what the cost will be
the falcons supposedly interested in
trading out of the four spot
what would it take to go up five spots
it would not be cheap when you consider
what the 49ers gave up to go from 12
to three hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports